si le principal travail des moniales de
bouzy la forêt de prier il en est un
autre est essentielle pour assurer leur
subsistance
c'est la fabrication d'un produit
d'hygiène vieux de 400 ans l'eau
d'émeraude
c'est ici qu'il est fabriqué quelques
mètres du monastère et ce jour là ses
soeurs anne qui nous fait la visite
si c'est là qu'on reçoit le miel donc
parce que l'autre d'émeraude est fait à
partir de miel et de trois plantes
lamente le romarin et la sauge
première étape le moins de quatre
opposés dans des fûts quelques jours
beaucoup d'eau puis mélangée à l'eau et
aux herbes direction la salle de
fermentation où tout se joue presque ici
d'oxygène un petit peu le produit
donc c'est pour ça que vous voyez de la
mouche au dessus donc je mélange pour
que vraiment le miel se dissolvent voilà
donc ce matin on est à 26 2 c'est pas
mal elle est presque fini celle là la
vente de lots d'émeraude est essentiel
pour les treize bénédictine elle
représente à elle seule 70% des
ressources générales de la communauté si
on n'avait pas ça c'est pas qu'on
pourrait pas vivre mais ça quand même ça
permet quand même d'avoir des facilités
de pouvoir envisager des travaux si on a
besoin parce que bon ça fait 20 ans
qu'on est là mais il commence déjà à
vous et à y avoir quelques soucis à
droite et à gauche
donc voilà il faut qu'on puisse assurer
de ce côté là aussi ce jour là sera née
plutôt contente
le liquide est de bonne qualité et les
stocks vont pouvoir se reconstituer
moi ce que j'apprécie aussi c'est que ça
nous permet d'être un peu solidaires de
tous ces gens qui travaillent
qui peinent aussi dans leur travail dans
leurs entreprises
vous avez besoin de ce côté manuel moi
j'ai besoin d'avoir un peu les pieds sur
terre on n'est pas complètement tout le
temps on experts chaque année ce sont
entre six à sept mille flacons qui
sortent du monastère la plupart sont
vendus en france
une petite partie est exportée en
allemagne aux pays-bas et en suisse